I hope they won't mind if I mention in
particular two nurses who stood by my
bedside for 48 hours
when things could have gone either way
this was Boris Johnson praising the
nursing staff who looked after him in
intensive care at st. Thomas's Hospital
Jenny McGee has spoken for the first
time about Harwick caring for the prime
minister and her surprise and his words
of praise my friends applying a joke on
me I I wasn't expecting it it was
totally out of the blue and it was just
shock just I couldn't believe that what
do you what he'd see it on TV I was
getting really really Phoenicia and I
was just doing my usual routine for
night shift and someone takes me just
the part that said Jeannie from New
Zealand and I was like wow I think
speaking to TVNZ in London Jenny said
the Prime Minister was just another
patient in desperate need of her help we
take it very seriously who comes in 20th
Kier these patients who come in to us
it's a very scary thing for them so we
don't take it lightly and he absolutely
need to be there Jenny's colleague Lewis
pitama from Portugal was also named
checked by the Prime Minister and had
this to say I don't have the words to
describe how I felt when I watched it it
made me quite emotional I was really
surprised but so happy I never thought I
would be highlighted like that the Prime
Minister's message really came from his
heart it was the most honest message I'd
ever seen I was very proud not only for
me but for all the team who looked after
him I was also really pleased he was
safe and out of hospital mr. Johnson is
now continuing his recovery at Chequers
Jenny and Lewis are back on shift at st.
Thomas's back on the front line of the
fight against Colvard 19 and the Brady
Sky News